irresponsible man let's take a baby  daddy let's take Nick Cannon that's  that's okay yeah  okay  are you happy okay yeah okay okay so  that's one arguably sexually  irresponsible man that's ten sexually  irresponsible women absolutely so again  it's more on like there are more  sexually irresponsible women than there  are sexually irresponsible men because  you guys might not know this but one out  of three men are either virgins or  haven't had sex in the past year where  the majority of women are sexually  active and there are more STD cases than  ever before yeah this is more out of  wedlock pregnancies than ever before  there's more abortions I actually I'm  not 100 sure I think there's more  abortions than ever before and and so  it's like is it on the men when most of  men aren't sleeping around that much  most men only around 20 of men can  really sleep around like that